Film Courage: I would imagine Bill that you
get emails everyday from people asking for
career advice.
Can you tell from some of the emails those
who really want help and those you may not
be able to help?
Bill Duke, actor, director, producer, author:
Yes.
There are people who
somehow they think something is going to be
given to them
and there are other people who they talk to
you for guidance about how they can get it
themselves.
The people who ask for guidance of how they
can get it for themselves, I’m interested
in them because they are not asking me to
do it for them.
They’re saying “You have experience and
I’m willing to listen to you so I don’t
make crazy mistakes" and so those people I
relate to because somebody did that for me.
People who come out and they just want as
you so eloquently spoke before notoriety they’re
not serious about this industry, not serious
about being a great actor or a great writer,
great producer, great director they just want
to be seen and have people know who they are.
I don’t take them seriously.
I have a foundation called Duke Media Foundation
we teach kids media literacy which what are
the jobs of the future going to be and financial
literacy.
If you make money, not just spend it, how
do you use it?
Plus the young kids that are serious if we
can get an opportunity to help them, we do.
I think there is validity in coming out here
with dreams and wanted just to be recognized
or notoriety but it’s not a serious craft
of industry, it’s just some insecurities
that you have that you want to overcome.
Film Courage: So when you receive an email
how can you tell the ones that really are
looking to find ways so they can then do it
themselves and those who want just a hand
up?
Bill: They say it.
They’re very clear.
There are some people who are so unaware of
how this place works.
They’ll say “Oh I want an agent and I
know you have an agent.
Can’t you just introduce me to your agent?”
And I’m saying “Do you have any pictures?”
“No I don’t have any pictures?”
“Do you have a reel?”
“No I don’t have a reel.”
“Have you ever acted in a film or play?”
“No, but I have an acting teacher.
And people think I’m handsome, they really
think I’m beautiful and they think I’m
talented.”
What do you say to that?
God knows I wish you luck but you’re coming
out here with nothing.
Do you want me to just drive you to meet my
agent?
It doesn’t work that way.
Then there are kids that have pictures, resumes,
decks if they have a project, they have decks
for their project, pictures, actors attached,
they’ve done the research for the demographic
of what they’re trying to sell to, return
on their investment, how much money it…now
when I see that I’m like “Whoah!
C’mere let’s talk because you’re serious.”
I can teach you but you don’t need that
much teaching.
All you need is opportunity, see that’s
a different experience.
If you’re just looking for “I want to
meet your agent.”
I don’t want to be mean but I just can’t
do that.
The Agent says to me “Why’d you bring
that person here?”
“They wanted to meet you.”
That’s not good.